I am a lover of cinema I believe and
this is my opinion that cinema is the
highest form of art that there is a
glimpse of what's possible a taste of
our divinity a great film is as they say
truth 24 times per second
now today everybody's talking about
mindfulness meditation everybody's
talking about the importance of learning
to be present learning to be in the here
and now to let yourself become immersed
and enveloped by the power of the
present moment and look conventional
forms of meditation work for many people
and I commend these practices as
therapies that focus your attention in
the here and now but for movie lovers
like me
I believe the ultimate form of
meditation is watching the cinema I
believe when you watch movies
consciousness meets its own process I
believe that when you get immersed in a
film and you assume the viewpoint of one
of the characters who effectively step
outside yourself I also believe that
when you watch a film you actually take
a journey within right you are the
characters and they are you and the
content plate of introspection the self
searching that happens as the story
unfolds on screen is a very powerful
almost supernatural experience space
time and mind invert and collapse you
know a movie may only be empirically 120
minutes two hours by the clock but when
you're inside of the film and you're
looking not at the screen but into the
screen time no longer exists you are in
a meditative trance and during these
moments of complete immersion when you
are enveloped in that other world that
absolute unmixed attention becomes a
form of Prayer you heed to it you submit
and surrender to it and you are cleansed
because it's a psychic carwash it D
fragments the hard drive it's like a
total immersive flow statement when you
come out of the movie oh my god it's
like you've been cleansed you've had
catharsis you've experienced the
mythological motif
you've taken the hero's journey and this
my friends is a kind of cosmic baptism
it's like a bath in the ocean of the
Holy every time a film envelops you
every time you become one with the movie
you've had a transcendental meditation
this is what I believe and this is why
when people tell me oh my god you got to
get into mindfulness meditation and this
and that I tell them it already exists
it's called cinema and on top of that it
throws a beautifully patterned story for
good measure so not only do you get to
meditate you get to go on a
journey an ecstatic illumination and pop
out on the other side and say thank you
I am so glad that movies exist so that's
what I think about cinema as meditation
[Music]